so a lot of entrepreneurs ask me they
say pal what can I do to build an
international global business I want
money coming from all over the place and
I always tell them when it comes down to
marketing if you can master marketing
locally you're going to be able to do
marketing globally so today's message
it's 14 different strategies I'm going
to give you that I personally use myself
I think I've used 12 of them myself on
guerilla marketing tactics you can use
and guerrilla marketing locally to get
the word amount out about your business
and what you're doing so let's start off
with the first one here cash in on viral
trends so today there's a lot of trends
there's website they can go and say
trending topics and you can always
figure out a way to you know cash in on
that Jessica she bakes cookies on the
side and one the story she was telling
me that got picked up on media all over
the place was she you know these fidgets
spinners that are very hot nowadays my
kids have two of them I was in LA the
other day my niece and nephew were
talking about how they're trading a gold
one for green one and all this other
stuff Jessica made fidgets spinner
cookie and all she did is make a video
and she took a bite after was done
spinning and suddenly goes viral who
picks it up by the way all these how
much traffic did I bring you how much
attention to Dublin to your brand so now
think about it now this fidgets spinners
may not work a year from now but it
works today because it's everywhere
right cashing on current trends there's
plenty of ways of doing it number to
partner with local businesses I remember
when we first got started and I had to
start our financial business nobody knew
about our company about the truth PHP
whose PHP whose PHP we had one office in
Northridge California with no one
knowing about it and this was in October
of oh nine and I said listen Halloween
is coming around the corner we got to do
girl on marketing at the highest level I
went to a local Quiznos couple of them a
guy I really liked his name is Nasir he
owned one the cords note that's an
answer are you willing to give a soft
drink away for free if I have hundreds
of people that come to you that buy
sandwich regular side but I need you to
give the software it's offering for free
is absolutely I said great I will design
the flyer
we'll give them away and when they come
to you I need you to tell them how proud
you are of the partnership with PHP and
it says great so I explained to who we
are he knew who we are he had known me
for many years so we went on Halloween
day we gave away 35,000 of these flyers
on Halloween while everybody's going up
there looking at these homes 35,000 he
calls me says hundreds of people have
come in here for sandwiches they have no
clue what the hell you guys it but I'm
so busy it's insane and suddenly all
these customers were saying man this big
this PHP this PHP company is so amazing
their partnerships up we got so much
attention that gave us momentum to kind
of get it going so find ways to partner
we'll look I've done it with dry
cleaners I'll go to a dry cleaner saying
if I bring somebody over to you or you
willing to give them two shirts as long
as they do four shirts yes there's so
many different ways for you to go out
and get guerrilla marketing locally
three flyer marketing one of the things
I need to know about flyer marketing is
that this used to be very effective and
a lot of people say oh I don't know if
it's still effective it's still
effective but you'll see it everywhere
campuses you're still seeing that this
video is also sponsored by fiber and one
of the things I love on fiber is I love
it when you can go on fiber your new
entrepreneur yourself you want to get
the word out about your business have
three different designers design a flyer
for you always use three three different
designers design a design a flower for
you and you'll tell them here's what I
want to look like I want it to be
creative at cetera et cetera they'll
bring you back to you create a cool
flyer if you use a code path better
coupon code path bet you'll get a 20%
discount on the entire purchase that you
make just make sure you do one whole sum
together because it's 20% on the first
purchase that you make once you do this
you have your fliers locally you can
find a ton of people that are willing to
go out there and put thousands of
flowers out there for you find five 10
15 different people locally that'll do
this for you next thing you know
sometimes all it takes when you do the
math if I put out 10,000 flyers that
people say Pat I've put that 10,000
flowers I only get two customers or five
customers if they cost you 500 dollars
to do it but you're
profit is going to be $3,000 was it
worth it yes it's 6x it's not a bad
formula to do it doesn't mean it's to
almighty but it's one of the ways that
works number four column all there's a
lot of services out there that
politicians use I think one of the
things that salespeople can learn a lot
from is politicians when they go
campaign I'm not talking about how they
are going to how they get people to vote
and all this other stuff but the way
they campaign and they get their message
out to you and I to vote for them
there's a lot to be learned on marketing
from that call them all as a service
where companies you give them five
thousand numbers three thousand numbers
100 numbers fifty numbers a hundred
thousand numbers and you record a
message and this automatically calls and
sends messages simultaneously to five
ten fifty a hundred thousand people at
the same time by the way many of the
politicians who have done this users in
the past they'll have a celebrity leave
a message for you and I and they'll say
my name is Robert De Niro let me tell
you why I'm voting for
Papapa my name is Arnold Schwarzenegger
let me tell you why I'm voting for this
and it's effective but it's one of the
ways you can do it again one of fourteen
ways you can do it number five water
bottles water bottles something I've
used for many many years you know always
the way with water bottles on how
effective it is think about what you
live right now wherever you live right
now I want you to think about the last
time that you got done doing something
where you said I would love to have a CO
bottle of water and nothing was around
and imagine what happens how we feel
when we take that first sip of cold
water you feel like you're in heaven
right where you can provide that
experience of heaven on earth to other
people where at the end of a hiking
trail so imagine a trail that's very
famous in your area and thousands of
people go on a Sunday or Saturday where
you go out on the bottom you buy a bunch
of our water bottles locally buy the
smaller ones and get hundreds of them
put them in the whole ice bucket have
them there and people are coming out
have the wrap around it be local real
estate agent your picture on it with a
phone number local and Insurance Center
your picture on their phone number
whatever it is that you're going to be
marketing when they come down Hanuma
bottle of water and say listen I know
you're thirsty here it is you don't have
there's no money we want nothing from
you but my informations under if you
need any of
but real-estate please feel free to call
me you hand out 100 bottle water bottles
of water how many of them are going to
really do business with you every one of
them no but if three do business with
you you make 17 grand on Commission was
it worth $100 on bottles yes
again another method of guerilla
marketing number six local charities
partner up with local charities that are
taking place you can do runs you can do
all these other things that's going on
marathons then ask I would do this if
the entire staff is going to wear my
shirt with the statements that says
such-and-such
are you okay with that yes perfect part
number local charity give them your
resources they can give to them but also
in return have them help you find a way
where your face is going out there to
them worth it's a bag everybody gets you
want something unique to be in the bag
if it's a package you're getting
whatever it is you're given information
to them so all the people that are
participating in this charity they're
also finding about what you're doing by
the way number seven piggy bank one of
the things I did with piggy bank was
phenomenal is I wrote out who my client
was I want husband and wives with kids
was my client because I was I'm selling
life insurance husband wife with kids
watch what I did kids I want him to
start saving money so every client I
went out to and we were writing business
I said hey you mind if I give you a
little Johnny gift yeah no problem
Johnny c'mere so Johnny this is a piggy
bank I'm giving this piggy bank to you
and I'm starting you off with the first
five dollars I put in the piggy bank the
logo of our company was on there I'm
giving this to you when you get to $100
I need you to call me once you get there
I'm gonna give you the other $100 okay
because saving is very important mom and
dad saw I just caught this something to
the kid right
he got $5.00 he's a lit up because $5.00
a lot of money to 6 year old or 4 year
old or 10 year old so he gets that money
he goes away the husband and wife have
to call me when he gets $200 that's the
second time I get a chance to talk to
the client to find out how everything is
and if I need to go back and write more
policies do more business get more
referrals or just to find out everything
is okay this was such a big kid that all
our agents started doing that we
couldn't keep these piggy banks because
there were so many being bought so the
piggy bank you can do locally number
eight book what is a book influencers
the first book I wrote 25 lots were
doing the impossible I didn't have a fan
page I didn't have a YouTube channel i
wasn't on twitter i wasn't on you had
nothing going on so I wrote the book 25
lots were doing impossible and then I
said I want to tap 100 influencers name
these were CEOs people who owned sports
teams all this other stuff we got the
names 100 of them I said I want to mail
two copies to each one of these
influencers I send two copies and I
wrote a letter I said here's a book I'm
sending to you I sent two copies because
one is for you and one is for your
system in case if you want your system
or somebody else to read it to tell you
about it and you end up reading because
I know how busy you are
so I send us out we didn't hear anything
for 90 days 90 days later I got an order
for 25,000 copies in Russia
I have no idea how I made it out to
Russia we never send it out to Russia
but a person got their hands on Russia
China Poland Romania locally we got
thousands of orders simply because I
send this out 200 influencers number-9
t-shirts t-shirts always works sometimes
on t-shirts you know we would make
t-shirts on with it ask me about dot dot
ask me about such-and-such and that was
effective because when your employees
are your staff or your sales people go
out on a Saturday or Sunday people will
ask so tell me about this so tell me
about that and teachers also works when
you give them away cool little quotes on
it with your logo on the back there's a
lot of ways to use t-shirts number 10
snapchat filters if you do it on a very
very massive area with 50 mile radius
you're going to spend hundreds of
thousands of dollars but if you do
within within a one-mile radius and it's
a university or school it's not that
expensive you become one filter and
people see it and that's another way of
guerrilla marketing it's cheap to do it
you can go find websites to do it's not
that expensive to do that number 11
social media image change so imagine if
you have a hundred employees imagine if
you got 200 employees say you have 50
family members friends that you guys all
run a company together you have an
initiative you want to launch what a
month of June we're going to be doing
XYZ on that day everybody changes their
image for one week your image on
Facebook for one week to whatever it is
what is this
this week we're giving dot-dot-dot no
problem you can do that on your fan page
you can do it on your personal page you
can do a lot of different places that's
also effective number 12 wrapping cars
some people save a pod wrapping cards is
$1,500 I don't want to wrap a car I
understand I'm just giving you one of
the ways nowadays you can have people
who you wrap their cars and they have
death to commit you of writing a minute
driving a minimum of ten thousand
dollars per year and all you do is pay
$300 a month with your car payment and
they're willing for you to wrap their
cards there is that service out there we
wrapped an RV we bought an RV with a
mass of 36 foot RV six of us lived in
the RV and we went 10,000 miles from LA
to Miami to New York to Toronto back to
San Fran back to LA and I spoke in front
of thousands of people during that time
and we shook hands met a ton of people
the entire RV was wrapped then we did it
again we took top four of our executives
in the company we put them in the RV
they went all over the nation the amount
of traffic and attention that God was
amazing simply because of an RB rep
number 13 keyword twitter hashtag let me
tell what I mean by this if you can
figure out a way late at night safety 11
o'clock I do a lot of this at 11 o'clock
I used to sit around 11 o'clock go 1
o'clock in the morning on Twitter alone
and go look at hashtags go look at
conversations and participate in that
conversation
participate in that dialogue you will be
amazed how many relationships can be
built based on whatever product that is
that your marketing with Twitter hashtag
you can't fully do this on Facebook you
can't fully do this on LinkedIn you can
do it sometimes on YouTube I think the
most effective way for this is Twitter
last but not least his shoes when I
first started as a financial advisor at
Morgan Stanley teen when I was 21 years
old I got started a day before 9/11 and
I'm Middle Eastern from Iran and every
single news station was talking about
the Middle East every foxy and
everything and I'm going on appointment
and I'm 6 5 to 40 I already look
intimidating I'm trying to tell people
invest a few million dollars with me
right I have to figure out a way to be
creative so for me to get through the
door of an assistant of
executive a you know system whatever it
is had to be creative so I made a list
of investors I found who were
millionaires in the community I was a
part of Glendale California within a 50
mile radius is what I did I made a list
I went to pay less and I went to DSW the
SW had shoes that were 70% off like
invite you for 17 dollars $18 $22 I took
this 100 names and I send them one shoe
in the Box one shoe they would open the
shoe box with a letter in the wiser one
shoe in here the letter would say mr.
Jones I really respect the way you do
business the reason for me sending this
to you is because I would love to spend
15 minutes with you to tell you about
what I do the reason for the shoe in the
box is to represent the fact I got I got
one foot in the door please help me get
the second foot in the door by meeting
between for 15 minutes I certainly hope
you appreciate the humor here that's
being used I would love to get together
with you if you do great if you don't I
totally understand I hope you appreciate
it you know how many people call me back
you know how many appointments I got
simply by doing that it was creative now
I want you to keep something remind you
about guerilla marketing these are for
tax I could tell you 300 different ways
on what I've done with guerilla
marketing over the years and we're just
trying to keep these videos we don't
want to go 45 minutes to an hour videos
these 14 ways have worked for me over
the years
the thing about guerrilla marketing that
you gotta understand is there are no
rules in guerrilla marketing there are
laws that you have to fall but there are
no rules you can be as creative as you
want to create with guerrilla marketing
you can say iPad I like what you said
about water bottles but I'm thinking
about combining water bottles with their
flyers no problem be creative about it
it'll be effective with guerrilla
marketing so by the way if you've done
some kind of a guerrilla marketing
that's worked for you effectively I want
to know about it so comment on the
bottom and let us know how you yourself
have used some guerilla marketing
methods tactics that work for you that
we can all learn from in the audience of
value team and other value painters can
learn from you as well and if you have
any questions thoughts comments comment
on the bottom as well if you have not
subscribed click on the button here to
subscribe to the channel and click on
that little alert button to be part
notifications everybody
[Music]